treatment drug resistance and even in
the field of ecology
we are also glad to announce the
upcoming hackathon on microbiome in
health and wellness this is an
initiative to provide students with a
platform to Showcase their Innovative
mindset of problem solving here each
student will have the opportunity to
develop a mini project around the
hackathon topic form a team with at
least two students and compete against
each other for mentorship support from
established companies and long-term
interests from the business Community
the applications of hackathon are in the
fields of obesity and Precision
Nutrition Innovation and beauty products
and in pregnancy so I would like to urge
all the participants to be a part of
this hackathon and make the most out of
such a wonderful opportunity to know
more about the event you can visit the
link that will that will be provided to
you in the chat box by one of our team
members
so before we begin with today's session
let me also take a brief moment to
introduce you to the team behind the
program
we are a us-based by informatics company
who's working with multiple academic and
Commercial collaborators to develop easy
to use analytical tools and our mission
is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
the omics logic training has been
completed by over 24 000 participants
from 187 countries in over 300 workshops
and due to this fast growth our team is
working with local and Regional
coordinators that are helping refine
local program Logistics and adapting
them to the needs of students and
researchers around the world and this
training has been completed by
participants in six different
specialization tracks which includes
oncology infectious diseases Precision
medicine Neuroscience data science for
biomedical data and comprehensive
training on omix data analysis
so how do omixologic resources help
Advance bioinformatics teaching Omens
logic is important for practical and
theoretical learning of bandformatics it
takes a combination of training modules
data analysis tools curated project data
sets and interactive session with
mentors to give the student a clear path
up the Bloom's taxonomy primarily and no
matter what the user's initial
experience with bioinformatics is
women's logic is a useful tool for
gaining a baseline knowledge of the
theory behind bioinismatics analysis of
large data sets and introduction to
basic coding languages like R and python
or even beginning a data analysis
project
the program comes with an access to the
omics logic courses which includes
courses on bioinformatics Precision
medicine multi-omics including genomics
transcriptomics epigenomics data science
that includes bioinformatics using RN
python as well as cheminformatics
users will be given directions to an
example projects of different fields
which you could learn from and replicate
for your research work users will be
given directions to access the T by info
platform for bioinformatics processing
and Analysis of data and the platform
includes demo pipeline as well as data
management and Cloud analysis Cloud
infrastructure to run bioinformatics
pipelines different stages of analysis
are performed in different sections on
this multiomics platform
so first of all let's begin by signing
up on the omics logic learn portal
before that let me walk you through a
brief demo on what a completed profile
on the portal looks like
so once you sign up on the portal these
are the features you need to keep in
mind that is a completed profile will
have a profile image full name with
appropriate capitalization
link to your social media handles which
could be your Facebook LinkedIn
Instagram or kaidi or even Twitter and a
brief bio about yourself that will
consist of your educational background
and research interests the mentors can
view your progress under the activity
tab the courses you are currently
completing will appear under the courses
tab finally after the completion of your
course the certificates will appear
under the certificates tab so with that
let us Begin by signing up on the portal
I'm sharing the link in the chat box
please click on the link and I'll walk
you through the process behind signing
up on the portal
all right
okay or just we has already shared the
link in the chat box so for users who do
not have an existing account on the
portal please click on the create an
account option that you see here
and here you will be asked to enter your
name email ID and provide a new password
you also have the option to sign up
using any of your social media accounts
this could be your Google account
Facebook account Apple account GitHub
account or even Twitter account and with
that I'll pause for a couple of minutes
for the participants to sign up and once
you have signed up please put a yes in
the chat box also if you're facing any
technical issues you can put them in the
chat as well and a team will be happy to
help you
so I'm waiting for the responses from
the 59 participants that we have
words
so once you sign up on the portal please
put a yes in the chat box so that I know
I can proceed further
all right
okay great
so since I already have an account on
the portal I'm going to click on the
login now option and click on the sign
in option to login
once you sign in you will be able to
view the various courses and example
projects that are appearing under the
core system so here since most of the
participants are interested in meta
genomics
when you put the keyword meta genomics
you're able to see the coursework on
metagenomics also the various example
projects that include role of high fat
diet and obesity effect of dietary fiber
intake on microbiome effect of
non-antibiotics and red syndrome and
coming to most important part as I
discussed when you click on the tab that
says welcome with your email ID
it will take you to the account settings
here so how do you edit the features
that I mentioned before for that when
you click on the icon that says profile
you'll be able to edit all the details
necessary details to update your account
so this could be your bio here you
should update your education background
and research interests name should be in
appropriate capitalization link to any
of your social media handles so in my
case I've linked my LinkedIn account and
my arc ID and under the activity tab the
community manager and the mentor will be
able to track your learning progress
once you start completing any courses it
will appear under the courses tab so in
my case I'm completing the python course
too and once you have completed any
project and uploaded on the portal it
will appear on the under the projects
Tab and if you're enrolling for any of
the programs such as metagenomic data
analysis program it will appear under
the programs Tab and finally after
completing the courses you'll be able to
receive the certificates under the
certificate stamp so so far if anyone
has any queries please put them in the
chat box otherwise now I'd like to
invite Dr raghav to start with today's
session
so does anyone have any queries so far
if not I'd like to pass on the stage
over to you sir
thank you srigori thank you very much so
let me find ways to share my stream and
set up uh the presentation
can you see my screen and it can also
hear me
yes sir
okay thank you very much let me
organize this a little bit so that I can
follow your chat also
okay
so welcome to omixlogix metagenomics uh
program and Session One
so uh in this specific course we are
going to introduce you to the
bioinformatics analysis of metagenomic
sequence data so in today's session in
this first session we will start by
speaking about genomic sequencing
Technologies as one of the methods to
study microbes and to map out how such
data can be used to understand the
biology
of the host system then we will
introduce you introduce you to several
data analysis tools for the metagenomic
studies and see a couple of examples
where such analysis approaches have been
used
so let's start reviewing a little bit of
history of microbiology where this study
of microorganisms led to the creation of
tools and creation of approaches that
are still being used today to continue
and to understand the world which we do
not see but yet has such a profound
effect on everything around us
so for for many many years the smallest
things that humans could see was about
as wide as a human hair when the
microscope was invented suddenly we saw
a new world that is living under uh our
own eyes as in in our water in our food
all around us the first observation of a
bacterium was made around in 19 uh in
sorry in 1673 by uh
by Anton van
leeuwen huik that's a that's a name that
I do not know how to produce it
pronounce even after so much so many
years so thanks to the development in
microscopes and we can now uh see what
he saw 50 to 300 times
um enlarged so as the resolution of the
tools that we use to observe these micro
uh microbes and bacteria improved more
and more representatives of these unseen
and unknown world have been discovered
today the microscopes as we know are
tremendously powerful and this allows us
to see smaller and smaller and smaller
elements that reveal how the world of
microorganisms function and how they are
related to the other
microorganisms and to our own hosts
environment so in this particular image
we can see a super high resolution
picture of
of bacteriophages that are in green
attacking E coli bacteria so this is
imaged with the helium ion technology
which produces the super high resolution
picture of this such as small world
so
the field microbiology is defined not
only by the organisms that we study but
also by the tools that is used to study
them and the tools that we use have
evolved to allow us to study and
categorize these microorganisms right
the technology for for example for
understanding bacteria is usually in
bacterial culturing coupled with
techniques to stain these bacteria and
these methods improves our ability to
isolate to classify and to determine
whether a bacteria or a microbe is a
cause of human disease or it is even
appropriate to
select some of the
um
um specific treatments attacking and
neutralizing those specific bacterias
right for example the discovery of
culture media allowed for the
development of this microbiology in
around 18th to 19th century bacterial
culture is the artificial medium that
allows the growth and isolation of
bacteria the first two have isolated
bacteria is
is a scientist that we all very well
know this Lewis pasture right and
staining as we already spoke about is a
technique that is used to differentiate
bacterial species into two large groups
that is gram positive and gram negative
based on the physical properties of the
cell wall of the bacteria so why is this
necessary it's a gram staining gives
results much more quickly than culturing
and this is extremely important
for example when an infection would make
an important difference in the
identifying an infection would make very
important differences in the patient's
treatment and prognosis some of the
examples are meningitis and septic
arthritis each one of these diseases are
caused by a gram negative and
gram-positive bacteria so identifying
which one treats what is very important
which one causes what is very important
to uh for developed for developing
prognosis and
better diagnosis
so the connection generally the
connection between microorganisms and
the diseases that it can cause has been
established in 1800s right as early as
1800s and these studies there are
numerous studies that proves or provides
important information about the function
of the bacteria in isolation however
more and more studies reveal that these
bacteria and the microorganisms they do
not live in isolation as we used to
study them using cultural meat cultural
media and using staining methods but
these microorganisms they live in
complex communities and many members of
these complex communities
are are uh are not known or not even
studied or not are completely uh unknown
and uh and are uh and cannot be uh
isolated to study in uh in the culture
or any uh staining media so today we
know that this community of
microorganisms as we call them as
microbiota that make up for example
human microbiome is not just unicellular
organisms that are living aside each
other but they are highly regulated
highly structural and functionally
organized communities of bacteria virus
and fungi attached to the surfaces of
our organs and our tissues which usually
cause we call them or term them as
biofilms with collaborations among
themselves that contribute to their
stability and promote their beneficial
promote their benefits to our host and
Iran to the host environment that is us
so how can we study these multitude of
micro
microorganisms that cannot be cultured
or that cannot be identified using
traditional methods like staining or
culturing Etc so around 1980s or 1970s
we identified that these microorganisms
that that are yet not been understood
and studied can be uh explode using the
advancements in sequencing Technologies
and other omics Technologies so due to
these advancements in metagenomic
sequencing and several other
collaborative Comics Technologies
enormous databases of sequencing data
from such micro
microbial communities are available
and this availability of so much of data
has led to the emergence of
computational metagenomics which can
help us study 99 percentage of the
uncultivable microorganisms in context
to their natural environment
so the emergence of such metagenomic
sequencing methods and generally
sequencing methods has opened up a new
door in understanding microbiology and
not only in isolation from apart from
there or away from their natural
environment we can study them in their
natural environment and as their
function importance to maintain the
balance and symbiosis of the natural
environment in a healthy state
so one such example is uh is taking our
skin cells or taking our skin samples so
we already spoke about bacteria or
microbes that are able to grow
um
in complex communities and they can
actually
grow or get other to almost all surfaces
or every surfaces and these adherence to
every surfaces and due to these other
surfaces they form complex communities
and these complex communities of
bacteria on any such surface basis or
any such living surfaces are termed as
biofilms right the stability of these
communities is is probably very
important and is fascinating also
to understand
um
uh from common uh
skin conditions point of view for
example as eczema acne and dry skin in
compared to healthy skin uh why because
forming such distinct communities these
microbes and microorganisms are
interconnected and they are determined
to maintain their community and their
balance and their healthy uh
maintenance of their Community is very
important to us to maintain the healthy
state of our skin in this example right
so any bacterial Community or any
bacterial group within a biofilm can
communicate with each other by producing
by detecting and by responding to small
signal molecules and this method is
called Quorum sensor right and this such
communication benefits the bacterial
Community for for colonization for
defense against competitors and to adapt
themselves to any changes and any stress
to the environment right and and
these sensing activities are also
involved in the pathogenic potentials of
some bacteria and the virulence of some
viruses and bacteria and this therefore
extremely important to understand
um how bacterial infections are
controlling and how bacterial infections
are affecting the uh
symbiosis or by a balance of microbial
communities and their abundance in these
biofuels right
and inside each Community as we already
spoke about that is generally a balance
of the amount of bacteria the amount of
fungi the amount of viruses that
controls species abundance and species
activity so this identifying the uh this
balance of these different species is
key to understand the healthy state of
the sample for example in this case
healthy state of the human skin are a
diseased state of the skin under
conditions like Xmas skin acne
etc etc
so human microbiota is for example
estimated to be around
um
10 to the power 13 or 10 to the power 14
of microbial cells and that is
approximately one is to one microbial
cells to human cells ratio
this number or these figures are derived
from the total bacterial cells that is
identified in Colon in the organ colon
where we have around
4 into 10 to the power 13 bacteria
identified colon is the organ as we now
know Harbors the densest number of
microbes or microbial communities
however each one of these microorganisms
that is present in environment like
colon or any other organ
um
can be explored for they carry important
functional properties and important
functional uh
contribution to maintaining the
healthiness of that specific tissue and
organ right and these the importance of
these specific bacterial community and
their functional properties can be
explored by characterizing the genomic
information of these specific microbiota
and the these properties and the genomic
information about the microorganisms
have been of growing interest to the
scientific Community as we can see it
has resulted over 80 000 Publications
until now right and the majority of the
studies that we can observe have been
focused on understanding the intestinal
microbiome or other ways called as gut
microbiome but as we discussed other
organs and their microbiota are also
becoming increasing topics of interest
in the latest metagenomics research
trend
for example inflammatory and microbial
influences between gut and between uh
skin for a healthy State and dysbiotic
State can be explored and this is
actually explored in this specific
publication and uh what do I mean by
understanding that and they have
actually listed out or
explored or a tabulated specific
strains and specific communities of
bacteria that is associated with skin
microbiota under variety of disease
conditions and vulnerability of
um
imbalance or this bios dysbiotic skin
microbiota conditions right in addition
to exploring the skin microbiota for the
variety of these diseases one can also
relate to the abundance that abundance
of microbiota that is present in the gut
and their influence on the ah diseases
that one absorbs in the skin and this
relationship is known or is actually
termed that's gut skin access right and
um
for example uh how this is uh related
the intestinal and the epidermal
barriers are connected through the
circulatory system as we know and are
visualized here in a very small
visualization
um uh in a simplistic visualization
manner here right the dysbiotic state is
characterized for example that can be
characterized by for example impaired or
imbalance in the gut microbiome and um
it can reduce the mucous layer it can
reduce the immunoglobulin secretion it
can for example disrupt the barrier
between uh between the microbes and the
intestine it can also
for example lead to increased intestinal
permeation into the bloodstream and it
can also lead to some inflammation that
is that can and be observed around the
gut and again at the skin level it can
lead to impaired skin barrier imbalance
in the skin microbiome or reduced
for example antimicrobial peptides
production as we saw in column sensing
right that can
increase the probability of getting skin
rashes or lesions etc etc the gut on the
skin dysbiosis or imbalance right or
connected through the immune imbalance
themselves in this specific example this
publication deals with understanding the
imbalance in the production of helper T
cells or th2 cells or Tel lymphocytes
that is skewed when there is no or when
there is when the crosstalk between the
gut microbiome and the skin microbiome
is uh disrupted so if you are if you
want to check this publication I can
give you the link for this this is an
exciting and excellent study that
relates to microbial community and their
effect in skin conditions as such
so coming back to the presentation uh so
uh
such studies and since 1990s many
microbial microbiome Studies have
significantly Advanced through major
initiatives such as
metagenomics of the human intestinal
tract and and the subsequent human
microbiome project and tremendous
studies and huge Studies have been made
possible through
several advancements in metagenomic
sequencing and the result of these
advancements is that we we study not
only the gut microbiome we explore a lot
of skin microbiome lung microbiome
intestinal that we already spoke about
and even brain microbiota are starting
to get characterized each new project
represents asked opportunities and
challenges to determine which
microorganisms and how their abundance
play key role in the development of
certain environmental condition that are
necessary for maintaining the healthy
functions of human organs and which
abundance level can cause harmful
effects to our or harmful results to
these human organs in general
so in the past over the past decade uh
overall almost 2 billion US Dollars has
been spent on human microbiome research
and major projects are underway in the
United States in the European Union in
China Canada France
Ireland Korea Japan etc etc and these
Investments have confirmed the
importance of microbiome to human health
and development and for example to give
you a scale something around 20
percentage of human investment in such
research has gone into human microbiome
project which is creating the research
resources or the data that is necessary
to understand human microbiome and which
is one of the main goals of human
microbiome project that is to create a
reference date assets and and necessary
analysis methods necessary computational
techniques and necessary clinical
protocol calls to understand these
reference data sets of healthy American
human being right
so it is because of such huge
Investments and such potential uh that
we know and we also find that
several endogenous human microbial
communities can contribute to critical
metabolic and physiological and
immunological characterization of our
human body and these can be done by
understanding the differentiation and
maturation of the immune system this can
be done by for example understanding the
microbial influence on microbial
communities influence on the food
digestion and the energy generation on
nutritional levels metabolic regulation
and control of the fat storage etc etc
right and we can also extend this
Association to
processing and detoxification of the
stress and memory non-metal chemicals we
already spoke about the maintenance of
skin and this this is also involved in
maintenance of the mucosa barrier
function and this is again very much
related the microbial function and their
abundance level and their balance is
very much related to the development and
regulation of pro and anti-inflammatory
processes and they can also
Associated be associated with the
prevention of innovation and growth of
disease promoting microorganisms as
those pathogenic microorganisms can
cause disruption to the microbial
Community themselves
so what is in store for
bioinformatizations uh as such right
metagenomics as we know is the genomics
analysis of microbial DNA obtained from
their environmental obtained from their
natural uh
environment right and the tools that are
available to study these metagenomics
enable us to analyze or perform
population analysis of these
unculturable or these previously unknown
microbes ah and and this ability to uh
identify these microbes without any a
priority knowledge and and uh actually
helps us to open new doors in
disciplines like biology microbiology
ecology and environmental sciences and
biomedicals in research in general
this sequencing based examination of
metagenome is uh has become an extremely
powerful tool
for generating novel hypothesis and we
it will not be an exaggeration to say
that it has evolved itself into the
primary tool for understanding the
microbial community and microbes inside
uh in in their natural environment as
such
my animation is running slow
let it run
so what is the difference between
metagenomics and other omics studies
right unlike other omic studies
metagenomics does not involve or does
not study a single organism but it
studies the whole community at once it
can be
uh it can be uh paraphrased as a
snapshot of a collection of organisms
directly in their natural environment
and since the genomes that we can
sequence are so diverse this is
typically
um
accomplished by sequencing a specific
portion of the genome instead of all the
genomic material that is given or
present in a present in any given sample
and many of these methods are actually
as we know are answered are actually
performed using the Next Generation
sequencing techniques which either
focuses on sequencing the whole genome
or the whole transcriptome of the
microbial population as we spoke about
that is one possible option or we can
also sequence a selected Gene of the
micro of the specific Gene of a microbe
and this Gene is usually the 16s rrna
gene or we can also go for studying
selected portions of this specific Gene
that is 16
sr18g to study the hyper variable
regions that is present in these genes
so when you perform this analysis uh or
when you perform the sequencing methods
to a sequence a whole genome or
transcriptome you have the flexibility
to analyze these sequences and relate to
their functional characterization of the
microbes and when you perform uh 16s
rrna sequencing or a selected portion or
hyper variable amplicon sequencing then
we have the ability to
um
uh estimate the abundance levels of
these microbes and relate that to
differentiate relate that to the
biological uh um
conditions of the sample uh either at
least from the deceased state or healthy
state in general right
um this 16 is amplicon sequencing as we
mentioned is is fairly recently
developed technique that is very widely
used to study micro microbiome abundance
they are clean is environment right this
method focuses on isolating 16s or 18 is
ribosomal RNA and amplifying using PCR
amplification methods right this Gene
16s rrna Gene contains a hyper variable
regions which is also uh
um
it is termed as hyper variable regions
because they provide or they contain
species specific signature sequences
that is generally used for identifying
the species or taxonomic rank of any
microbial uh entity the benefit of this
amplification is actually tied to the
nature of sequencing read link which can
actually maximize the effective output
from the affordable sequencing
technology or in other words since we
are not sequencing the whole genome of
the max of the
bacteria or of the microbes
we are only focusing on specific portion
of the genome we can scale this up to
multiple levels at an affordable
sequencing rate
so General differences between what one
can achieve from uh shotgun or
metagenomics or meta transcriptomic
sequencing or amplicon based sequencing
is
can be summarized as this as we already
spoke about this the metagenomics or
meta transcriptomic sequencing can give
you Gene prediction information function
functional annotation of the genes that
are predicted and we it can give you
assembly of this genome for
microbes that are that are unknown or
that are not characterized so these
information are these analysis method
can be achieved using the metagenomics
or meta transcriptomics sequencing
method while the amplicon sequencing
method or 16s rrma Gene sequencing a
method can actually give you
uh uh
we can give you the abundance level of
different microbial population for the
different sample sizes that we are for
different sample conditions that we have
and relating the abundances and from the
abundance level understanding the
balance of different uh microbial
community and different phyla or genus
or family of microbial Community can be
extremely important analysis to
understand the biosis or balanced state
of these microbial communities in their
natural environment so if we take these
um
uh take the abundance entity your
abundance level of microbial Community
for a deceased State and compare it with
a healthy state so we are bound to see
differences in specific setup or
specific genus or phyla of bacteria that
can be related to uh generally can be
related to be the marker bacteria or
Marcus species for those specific
deceased state in general
um
yeah this is what is yeah this is what
it is done so this 16s Gene as we spoke
about are the hyper variable regions
that we can sequence
um from the 16s Gene are the ones that
are used to uh find a specific bacterial
taxonomy are are the ones that are used
to identify these bacteria as we will
um discuss in couple of slides so to
these genes are generally not identical
right I mean the 16s are in a gene in
their hyper variable regions even though
they are sequence specific or species
specific they are not identical but they
have their innate diversity and
variation and they are usually
combined or clustered into uh into what
we call as operational taxonomic unit
which can be used to classify groups of
grossly related individuals so these
otus are actually formed are actually
identified by clustering the genes or
the sequences uh that are that
represents either 99 percentage or 97
percentage ident at identity level one
of the shortcoming of such method is
that we may end up pooling two or more
than two different species or um genus
of closely related bacteria together and
in other words we can even sometimes end
up separating a bacterial species or
bacterial genus that may exhibit uh uh
um
um
a lower identity level a lower sequence
identity level uh at this otu or at this
97 or 99 percentage thresholder so that
is an Associated risk or that is an
Associated limitation of uh clustering
based on otus but there is another
method that is actually uh get that is
actually developing uh that is in right
now it is actually fully developed and
many of the
um quantification microbial Community
quantification methods actually started
adopting to amplicon sequence variance
right so we we spoke about the most
common type of clustering method for
identifying uh these microbial Community
has been the operational taxonomy unit
which generally uses a fixed sequence
identity cut off and that is usually 97
percentage for the sequence from the
space the same species but however as we
already discussed different regions uh
vary in and uh
and different species vary in their
sequence identity range and sometimes
phylogenically phylogenetically related
taxa can share less predictable sequence
identity range and
to accommodate them we cannot reduce the
level of sequence identity so these are
all
um current limitations of this otu
methods and in recent years we have come
to understand or we have come to use or
introduce denoising through several
different algorithms as an alternative
to the clustering method that is
generally employed to identify or
cluster these related sequence together
so these
these uh denoising actually helps us to
eliminate sequential errors before
forming custom before forming these
clusters and are hence referred to as
amplicon sequence variance so these as
we are amplicon sequence variants based
clustering is is
um is technically based on sequence
probability rather than sequence
identity as in OT the denoising
approaches uses a very well established
statistical methods to determine for
example which low prevalence sequence
appear more than that would be expected
for a at a noise level and therefore
that are observed to be valid sequence
variance and they also identify which
for example
um
sequences are identified or can be
identified as noise sequences and that
can that will be eliminated from there
uh further clustering uh
further clustering uh level isolation
and this results in fewer reads or fewer
sequences to uh proceed to the
clustering stage but it results in a
consistent custom clusters or consistent
sequences that can be identified as that
can be related at a specific identity
level which is also
um
performed at 97 percentage so in short
the denoising algorithms and the
statistical denializing algorithms that
we used to
employ before the clustering stage has
actually enabled us to identify uh
or to uh characterize these microbial
communities at an increased resolution
in the recent years and this has been
actively employed in methods like time
to uh
um over the existing
otu based methods in data to Pipeline
and etc etc are in traditional
metagenomics pipeline Etc so once we
have identified these clusters and their
representative sequences are actually
estimated and what do we do we actually
take these sequences
otu or ASV sequences and annotate them
by mapping on two reference database so
this reference database here we use is
the silver database which um which is uh
which contains taxonomic information for
different domains of bacteria Archaea
and Eukarya and their sequences of this
16s rrna Gene
tabulated and they are ah
yeah
stored in this repository by comparing
the sequences that we have identified in
these asvs and to their respective rrna
sequences and their hyper variable
regions in the silver database one can
associate these asvs or otps to their
specific
taxonomic ranks and their
specific genus and classes of these
bacterial species are different
microbial species
So based on this mapping of specific
regions that are Amplified as we already
spoke about from the 16sr RNA Gene in
the bacterial ribosome these asvs or
root used can be assigned to be
belonging to specific taxonomic class of
bacteria and this will help us quantify
the proportionate Community
proportionate level or abundance level
of these bacteria in this community so
each microbial Community can be studied
by comparing with each other and and
their abundance level can be compared
and
the abundance level can be related to
abundance level from the similar
communities can be related to different
conditions or different individuals and
generally we can create or we can
estimate
um
yeah a generic and a a normal a
microbial abundance level for healthy
individuals that is what is the aim of
human microbiome project as we already
spoke about so this analysis right
includes uh for example
um generally includes unlike other omic
data analysis this analysis includes
in-depth understanding of the data
preparation understanding what are the
reference databases that are actually
used for the mapping and specific
analytical approaches to answer specific
question based on
uh observation and evidence from our
results right importantly we will also
discuss how the sequencing data
represents only uh one type of microbial
omics with um
many more becoming increasingly
available for example uh
yeah in in addition to uh microbiome or
bacteria bacterial species we can also
explore the abundance levels of the
virus present in this microbial
communities from the byroom database and
we can also explore the
presence of different uh classes and
different
species of fungi present in any sample
um such studies are helpful for example
the viral studies are helpful in
understanding the pathogenicity of the
existing biroam in our meta microbial
community and fungi database or fungi
identification is very very beneficial
in understanding the environmental
effects on understanding the
environmental condition for
agriculture and agree genomics in in
general so generally the questions about
the role of microbial members and their
communities are now being answered
primarily using these next generation
sequencing genomic data and sometimes
this can also be supplemented and
complemented with
um Mass spectroscopy approaches to study
proteomics and metabolonics so what is
generally understand in latest last one
or two years of microbial metagenomic
studies the next phase of microbiome
research is lies in in the ability to
integrate a multi-ohmic state assets
that will combine this next Generation
metagenomics data set with the mass spec
or structural data or metabolomics data
to relate the functional metagenomics
with their phenotypical informations of
the metabolites that are
generally used for quarries column
sensing are generally used for the
well-being of the tissues or the
environment that these microbial
communities are sampled from
so in addition to this uh we we also see
that
um
uh
we spoke about the gut and skin axis so
the relationship between the microbial
communities that one observes in the gut
level and their effect on different
health conditions like uh
um
chronic Health diseases that gut liver
access and
neurodegenerative diseases at gut brain
axis are being actively explored at
different levels so to study them such
integrated approaches are necessary to
understand not only the association of
these
abundance levels of these microbial
communities to the different disease
State and their influence on the
metabolites that are they
actively
enriched and suppressed and are broken
down and are being saved are also have
to be integrated in this analysis to
understand their Disease Association and
healthy state general state of healthy
healthiness Association also right
so we have so far discussed a lot about
the history of microbiology and the
emergence of the sequencing technology
and how these data has been used and can
be used to study uh samples that um that
cannot be uh understood by traditional
methods like uh staining or culture
based methods so let me actually point
you to some of the additional resources
that you can make use from the learn
learn or mix logic platform to study
these Topics in Greater detail right
this will also these resources also
include practical analysis methods and
tools that you will get to tremendous
experience
with using a variety of data sets that
we will also discuss in a short while
right in the following sessions in this
program we will look at some of these
resources and lessons from these
resources we will look at example data
assets we will run the analysis together
and we will uh get an understanding of
the tools methods and examples that are
generally used to study microbial
community and their association with
different diseases and different health
conditions in general so let me give
couple of examples
if yeah so this SRI gauri also pointed
you to how to access these courses and
Associated resources from uh from the
learn platform so the materials in these
resources are
generally a course that includes
metagenomics lessons and many different
example projects that includes data from
different model systems for example this
data actually takes model system this
data actually contains
um
samples from Human gut microbiome and
this data contains samples from model
systems such as Mouse and this data
contains or this data integrates the
observation that is made in one
application and their relationship to
understand the microbial community and
their symbios dysbiosis effects on red
syndrome and neurodegenerative disease
affecting kids or children
so this we already know and these
courses are designed to provide you with
uh with proper explanation on the
objectives on tutorials with examples of
practical applications and Etc and the
reviews of those materials have already
been done by by SRI gauri earlier so
we're not going to go over this so let's
little discuss a little bit about some
of the Practical aspects of this
approaches and what we will discuss in
detail in this program so the structures
of the coursework and other details you
already have been briefed and you can
also get an idea by going through the
associated resources so what do we have
in in general so we
um
we understand or restructure the course
in such a way that you understand the
basic concepts of uh under applying
metagenomics uh
um data and Analysis for this
metagenomics data a different level
right at their functional level at their
Downstream analysis Level under their
specific Downstream analysis level uh in
r or Python's environment to uh to
specifically address the questions and
hypothesis that one can generate for the
data or for the uh sample that we have
in general so this is this also recovery
went through this so this is example of
what you can get and what you can access
from the T bioinfo server where we have
the resources like um demo pipelines
which gives you access to how to set up
this analysis Pipeline and once you have
completed setting up this demo Piper and
that will give you access to the output
files that are generated through these
analysis methods you are free to
download them and explore them using
methods like Excel and the pictures and
the interactive outputs can be explored
for their Association and for the for
understanding the patterns in the data
Etc so you are free to go through truly
in the metagenomics level but also other
different omics data level so the
the visual interface of T by info
platform can be uh used to study
metagenomics Approach at the whole
genome level and at the data two
amplicon sequencing act and also what
current two uh analysis methods which
which uses ASV
um based uh
bacterial taxonomic identification in in
comparison to otu based identification
indirect right and behind many of these
methods we we have uh this analysis or
we also have couple of we also have
important lessons on Downstream analysis
that can be performed using the data
that you can download from the
metagenomics pipeline and subjecting
that to
um Downstream analysis using popular
coding languages such as R and python we
have explained this into tutorials and
you will have access to those codes and
how to understand these codes also and
these coding tutorials actually start at
the beginner level so if you are not
familiar with this uh with this coding
platform you do not have to fret you can
either
um
uh base your understanding and Analysis
uh only on the server-based uh
server-based methods and code free
analysis methods but if you are if you
want to explore more into the coding and
development of understanding the
downstream analysis performed at the
metagenomics data our tutorials and our
lessons include
specific code blocks for data importing
for Preparation and pre-processing of
the data for the analysis and for
standard visualization to understand the
patterns in the data and processing of
the data and perform this analysis of
the data to relate the patterns observed
in the data to the phenotypical
condition not to the biological
conditions of the samples Etc
generally
so
yeah more specific packages and these
publication uh these ready outputs can
be accessed from these code based
tutorials and also from these output
and also from these pipeline outputs
that we will cover more in the advanced
lessons and yeah these are a couple of
examples of what you can generate from
these metagenomics pipeline
and uh so for for before going or before
uh
briefing some of the Practical examples
some of the projects that we will
discuss during this during the course of
this program let me stop here and ask if
you have any queries until now
if not just let's let's move forward and
discuss what can be studied and that
will give you generally an idea about
the potential of metagenomics data and
to where it can be approached or where
it can be applied to we have discussed a
lot already and we will gain some some
more information
with some specific publication examples
and practical examples okay
so there are many applications this
already we spoke about including skin
condition including foot sensitivity of
the drug of the gut including autoimmune
disorders and cancer antibiotic
resistant drug resistance and even
sometimes ecological studies that can be
performed uh based on the metagenomics
application or edit application so in
this specific program you will learn to
find the data you will learn to analyze
the data from repositories like human
microbiome project and from repositories
like ncbi and from generally obtaining
debt assets that include
their assets from American gut project
and Etc that we will also talk about
right we will also look more into uh
some of the control studies that can be
performed on animal models as we
discussed where the environment and the
environment in which these microbiome
are
are actually Harvard can be
um
it can be customized and can be
specifically altered to understand the
potential and to understand the effect
of this microbiome to their uh yeah to
there to their phenotypical
characteristics and their behavioral
aspects in this specific example that we
will discuss in the
program generally so in general this
microbiome research seems to be involved
in many more important areas of
microbiome or biomedical research for
example they can they are actively
currently used in screening for
Diagnostic signatures of chronic Health
diseases and they are also used to
understand for example
um in Precision medicine and um
and and in their and their response to
treatment efficacies and Etc and that
also explored and the therapeutic
considerations
for microbiome transplantation studies
are also performed and their
relationship to conditions such as
Alzheimer's and cancer also actively
explode
so these are all some potentials of
these metagenomics and microbial based
research and I have a question before
moving on let's see uh Stella asks can I
use 16 as full sequences long read
sequences to analyze practical Community
as well as functional analysis metabolic
pathways okay when the moment that you
say 16 is sequencing you are restricting
yourself to 16s rrna gene or the hyper
variable regions present in the 16s rrna
Gene so when you have such limited
sequencing potential you cannot perform
pathway analysis or functional analysis
we will not get or gain any information
on the gene or any other pathway
potential of the bacteria or other
microbes that are involved if you want
to study
genetic or Gene level functional
analysis of the genes from these
different my microbes you have to
perform whole genomics or whole
metagenomics or whole meta
transcriptomic sequencing and then
relate that or identify their sequences
to specific asvs or what to use in this
space in this case and then you can
perform or identify genes from these
different microbial microbial
um
you cannot say Partners you can say
microbial samples and microbial count
individuals and relate that to uh
pathway analysis related to functional
analysis related to meta transcriptomics
analysis and and metabolite analysis and
Etc so we have a technical question on
do primers use for amplica amplification
will introduce biases we will actually
get rid of these uh amplification based
adapters and primers at the
pre-processing stage that at the
pre-processing stage one of the
important
steps that we do is to get rid of the
adapter sequences and get rid of the
primers that is used in the library
generation method so let's move on let's
see what do we have some more
so
this program is mainly designed to
highlight the role of bigomics data
analysis that is that can be used to
understand uh not only metagenomics but
at different applications of omic's Big
Data bioinformatics analysis on chemical
informatics and different Therapeutics
and Diagnostics approaches and how
analysis on this structured data in
general is transforming the biological
research in general right you can
explore the other areas that is present
in the omics logic platform to make a
full use of the flag
so this is this is to highlight the
importance that the microbiome is not
only relevant in biomedicine or
biomedical research but it is an
important part in understanding uh
biotechnology of soil microbiome and
agriculture or acrogenomics in general
right metagenomic studies on
agricultural applications are actually
developing and they are showing promises
and many have already started to many
Research Laboratories and uh
and industries have already started
using this approach to improve the yield
or or change the conditions to improve
resistance of crops to specific
pathogenic
attack in general etcetera and um
this in addition to that in the current
uh scenario they can be used to
understand the microbial diversity uh in
on their relationship to hygiene
antibiotics antibiotic resistance to
General uh um
risk factors of urban living including
pollutants and etc etc and how they have
an effect on gut microbiome and how
these can be related to for example uh
in in Contracting or in in adverse
effects of adverse effects in terms when
one contracts covid-19 disease in
general so some of the Publications have
already started exploding lung
microbiome and their involvement in and
uh in the adverse effects of
uh of this covid-19 disease so if you
are interested in that you can check
couple of Publications in that right
which relates to the lung microbiome not
the gut microbiome lung microbiome and
the disease severity for similar viral
load on different patients with a
different lung microbiome abundance
right so uh at the end of this program
we aim that you should be able to find
analyze and interpret metagenomics data
on your own and if you have any
um queries so far please uh put that in
the chat box as as we mentioned so
um
you can also get in touch with us uh
using different communication methods
that SRI gauri and purchase actually
explain to you in how to reach us
so before the next session I urge all of
you to start going through the course
metagenomics and couple of introductory
lessons on on what on the
uh on the topics that we already
discussed today and that will help you
with uh with digesting lot of
information that we discussed on today
and prepare you for the uh for the
sessions that is for the next session
which is going to be on understanding
the sequencing Technologies for
metagenomics data analysis
so with that I conclude today's session
or my portion of the today's session and
hand over the podium to Sri gauri back
or sparsh I'm afraid I do not know
yes for myself
yeah thank you buddy okay
oh thank you thank you so much for such
a wonderful session I will now take up
the registration part and help all the
participants get started with the
program
so this is I can answer your screen all
right so this is the program page for
metagenomic data analysis program and
today we had the first session and a lot
of participants had some questions
regarding how this online program will
be structured so we thought of inviting
all the interested participants to the
very first session to give them an idea
of how it would be conducted and that is
why recession was free for all if you
wish to uh become part of the other
sessions that we have scheduled uh the
schedule can be seen on the program page
itself if you scroll down you can see
that all the sessions with their dates
and what topics would be covered on the
dates on these dates along with the
associated resources I mentioned on the
program page so if you wish to become a
part of the other sessions you can
proceed ahead with your registration now
so that it would be easy for us to share
with you the links to join the sessions
and also give you access to the
resources to get started and join our
community of bioinformatics researchers
so this is the session schedule that you
can follow along we have the dates
mentioned here the topics that would be
covered uh for each of these sessions
and along with each topic you have some
Associated resources that you have to
follow along to complete each session
these resources are lessons of the
metagenomics coursework on the portal
which includes the concepts session
videos and then you also have to attend
some quizzes and assignments to make
sure that you have got the understanding
correctly and submit your assignments on
our um support account
also once the session is completed let's
say you were not able to join the live
session or you are not available at that
time or you want to revisit the session
you'll find the recording of that
particular session on the program page
itself so today we had the first session
today was an introductory session where
the mentor introduced you to the field
metagenomics and 16 as metagenomic
sequencing and also give you an overview
of the entire course and the tools and
resources for this program
so after this video has been processed
I'm going to upload it on our program
page and you can access the video of the
program page of the session on the
program page only the registrants of the
program page will be able to have the
access
so if you are interested to become
become a part of this program please
make sure that you register
uh before we close the registrations
thank you so much sir for answering the
next question I was just in the chat if
you have the questions also so this was
about session schedule how you will get
the access to the recordings the
resources now let's jump on to the
registration part I request the
participants to please mute themselves
okay so how do you register yourself now
here we have three different
registration dates or I'll say three
different subscription types the first
one is where you enroll for 45 days and
get the access to to the resources for
45 days and here you will get the access
to the session recordings
um the same sessions as we have today
and also the coursework on the omnisogic
learn portal
the participants who enroll or take up
the 45 days of subscription will get an
educational license where they can run
their example pipelines with the data
sets given and the coursework and
practice along to see how the pipelines
work
all right and then you have the second
subscription that is for 60 days
so once the program is completed once
the training uh with all the sessions is
completed the participants for 16 year
subscription will get some extra time
to meet the mentor one-on-one have these
one-on-one sessions with the mentor and
work on a research proposal to get
started with a research project so they
learn get trained and learn how to work
with metal genomic data and carry out
the analysis and they finally apply the
knowledge that they gain to answer a
research question in hand so that is
about the second type of subscription
level a 60-day subscription
then you have the thought subscription
that is for 90 days here the
participants will get to work on a
research project and get it published
the outcome of the 90 days subscription
will be a publication where the
participants first of all complete the
training program and then they submit
their research proposal and then they
start working on the research project
and if everything falls in place if
you're able to reach the deadlines then
the outcome would be a research
publication the outcome for the 60 days
is a poster presentation that means that
you could present your research work in
conferences uh as a as a poster as a
research poster
and if you are from a different country
and not us you can simply click on this
icon here which shows all the different
currencies and you can click on this and
see what it would be in your own
currency
now we are offering scholarships to
low-income countries and also to
students
so please reach out to us on
Communications
bio and also
marketing.com it would be better if you
reach out to spurge directly at
marketing at the economics logic.com
for any questions that you have and also
for thank you so much for sharing the
details in the chat box uh we have the
WhatsApp number as well actor uh this is
a company number so you you can reach
out to sparsh for this she's the
marketing manager and she'll be able to
help you out with your enrollment and
your registration and also if you are
seeking scholarship and just quickly
share the scholarship form in the chat
box please fill out the form and uh we
will review your application and get
back to you on it
if there if there are any questions
please put it in the chat box so that we
can take it out and help you get started
here is the scholarship form I have
shared in the chat box yes here it is
peace fill the scholarship form and
we'll be able to help you get started
with the program with a scholarship
that was it that we wanted to discussed
today
if there are no more questions I think
we are going to end today's session but
if you have any questions that you would
like to clarify over an email then you
can reach out to sparsh on her mail ID
it is shared in the chat box we are
looking forward to meeting you all for
the second session
and in the second session we will be
discussing about the first Pipeline and
also the microbiome functional bacterial
Community you get uh we'll get you all
do a practical Hands-On on the very
first pipeline where you'll be able to
classify uh the otos
based on taxonomies
based on taxonomy level to be more
specific
the second session is on September 29th
and we are looking forward to meet you
all for the second session thank you
everyone for joining and have a nice day
we do have a query
all right listen uh we'll mail you the
answer all right thank you everyone I
hope to see you all for session two uh
yes I can take that question too okay we
have a question from lisna um question
on research project completion does the
90-day program required to finish a
project within the within the period to
research publication yes when when we
have a program on program for 90 days
for research fellowship or research
internship then you will be required to
complete the project within the 90 days
and that is the usual uh time period for
many participants like you listen so it
is not a tall task we will discuss on
what level are you currently and what do
we need to learn to promote you to the
level of Performing this analysis and
that we will decide on designer design a
research question for which you can
perform the
perform the project and work on the
project and
get the answers and depending upon the
depending upon the promise of the
project you can work with you can
decide on the you say it on the research
publication little bit later okay thanks
thank you so much sir so if no one has
any queries we will end today's session
and I hope to see you all for session
two thank you everyone have a nice day
thank you all
thank you